megan is an amazing emcee i feel like i  think  megan  oh she's nice what yeah she's nice what  that [ __ ] delivery i ain't gonna lie  she wanted him who inspires you  to get better as an mc not if not even  just females just in general like some  like maybe someone you've heard recently  we're like damn that [ __ ] is  nice like i gotta get on my [ __ ]  um  [Music]  [ __ ]  these [ __ ] like we gotta be with you  like you're not gonna have no  turnt up whack ass female rapper like if  if she turned up that [ __ ] is talented  cause we so [ __ ] analyzed dozier  those are killing [ __ ] that [ __ ] can  rap sing pop [ __ ] perform she she her  perfor i feel like her performing is  like i think she's the best performer  i've seen in a long time